look how cute you are I'm here you're
very little okay
this is just a quick personal video for
the weekend we have this why you walking
so far behind me Matt no cuz he's this
slow down ever you want when I'm behind
i'm taller sitting like I think you look
smaller we decided to walk a lot more
because I got back from a bunch of trips
I did a lot of traveling for my book and
they came back a few extra pounds yeah
that yeah a few extra pounds a lot of
Japan's a lot XJ yeah basically the
biggest ever been in my life so now
we're trying to walk everywhere play
catch yeah and we are heading off to the
bachata social dodge freaking out here
there's the tag okay and uh yeah part of
our habit too happy to be healthy we've
invited friends to now come out and play
catch with us so uh be healthy people
that's a message he acted see active go
for a walk it's beautiful day we live in
a great world and what else do you want
to say your face is numb Nina just came
back from the dentist so believe nation
leave some get well soon feel better
comments for Nina she can't say mouth
she says most now Mouse my face I can't
do this part I went to got Nina solution
because she didn't I didn't want her to
have to cook and she didn't I didn't
want her to have to eat my cooking
either yeah yeah I guess well I got an
extra walk in to go to the sushi please
oh you walked yeah I did how do you call
it too no no I walked see I got my walk
in I gotta next I got little bonus
walking on you we're done my walk friend
oh ok ok anything else good I forgot my
shoes what shoes my dancing shoes have
an extra pair okay good good everybody
needed to know that that's fantastic
okay so have a great weekend and leave a
comment and believe and we'll see you
soon bye